dan Marino joins us always great to see
Dan I do you have any more ISOTONER
gloves you know what I don't I don't I
wish I did for this do you have some no
but I remember going to a department
store and I thought you know what if
merino is selling these ISOTONER gloves
that they got to be really good and you
should you should but they were too
expensive I know I didn't they were too
far back that whole thing is I was a guy
living in Miami it's like selling ice
played it was one uh I want to say
Pittsburgh one time probably like 13
below or something how did that affect
you it's it makes it tough especially
when a game doesn't mean anything so was
it like it wasn't like a playoff game
anything it's like okay let's get back
to Miami
let's get out of here but when you're
playing in a game like now that's your
hometown though sure yeah so you still
have to step it up a little bit though I
mean I mean they kind of seen Danny
Marino so we played like the first half
and that was it they paid I can't
remember who the backup was then but
yeah I know you didn't get traded but
what happened Alex Smith how surprised
were you with that um I guess you know
because they probably felt like he was
gonna leave anyway yeah you know so get
some value you know so I mean that's
that's what I would look at it you know
so where does it's a little surprising
but you could see it happening
where does he sort of rank with
quarterback I know we love to do this
and it's probably not fair but just
assessing you know what is he 33 coming
off a 33 and he's played solid football
for a long time in the league yeah he
has you know and he's a guy to kid you
know obviously gets into playoffs and
give you a chance yeah if you could have
Kirk Cousins around like Smith who would
you take I'd rather have Tom Brady going
there
explain how Brady has become this
explain it well I mean I think it's
first of all I think it's the fact that
the combination of continuity of Bill
Belichick and him
yeah that's you know it's kind of like
with me and coach Shula like we're I
think they're way past us as far as
combination wins but I think we're third
now and it's that comic it's that
continuity combination that you could
build around that and that's that's
really where it is and then you know he
stepped up he's you know he's he's
pretty darn good is an understatement
yeah you know if you see what he was to
what he's become we look at you know
everybody's athleticism in 40-yard dash
and you know your arm strength and all
of this stuff Brady doesn't fit into
that category there
he's very accurate great arm strength he
does he has that you know that pocket
presence you know where he can move in a
pocket and he has the clock in his head
where he knows when to get rid of the
ball has all that stuff plus he competes
you know his beats his ass off you know
I mean it's that's it
is he better than Montana I'm not going
there oh wait wait come on he's bringing
this one that's you're not afraid I'm
not afraid
oh no no no no but like Brady's better
than Montana you're saying that yes yes
but I've said it to Joe when he sat
there I thought it Elway was what he
said he was fine he understood it yeah I
mean I I love Joe I mean because of all
the Super Bowl wins I guess you know you
gotta say Tom Brady but it's hard just
you know for me because because Montana
was such a great player Elway and all
that it's just stuff but but he's a
great great player man for sure we did
ask him about you know if you were at
the time it was Brady was four and two
as Montana yeah okay so we asked Montana
we're like you know what's better you
know for no or four and two and it goes
I don't know I can't answer I never lost
[Laughter]
it's good for Joe how long does it take
before the game slows down everybody
talks about this in a variety of sports
that it slows down for the quarterback
for me it didn't take long at all so I
made the Pro Bowl as a rookie you know
so I think it just that comes with your
preparation and the fact that you know
in college did you start a lot of games
in college
play log football in college because
then that experience you know makes it
easier for you when you come in league
and then the fact that I had a you know
for me I had a you know a good veteran
team it was in a Super Bowl two years
before so yeah that made it a lot you
know easier for me and yet good wide
receivers looper and Clayton when I
first came in that Moore was there
pretty good
and you also but were you doing a spread
in college yeah yeah yeah because that
was gone for wide receivers and some
empty stuff yeah when did that start in
college we started doing that probably
like my junior years but you had to be
remember that's been a while you you had
to be one of the first quarterbacks who
was playing in a spread offense like
that we did that but also we you know we
packed them in and we ran the ball to
you know because we had a great
offensive line at Pitt so I look at
these offenses now the NFL's adopt in
college offenses that is happening
because you see the young kids coming in
all that run pass option stuff is that's
a big part of it now and because they
because they do it so much in college
yeah you got to put that in your offense
you got to have that option because they
are successful at it and then it had the
bubble screens which I kind of hate
bubble screens but you know that's it
but if like today's offense Brady throws
the short stuff sure yeah could you he
takes shots too yeah but when you took a
lot of deep shots yeah I would snow we
threw a quick passing game too but I
would say that our offense was premise
to off of going down the field first and
then throwing check downs and could
you've done these little yeah I would
like to do it I wouldn't liked it yeah
but but it seems like that's the the
norm now there's a lot of it yeah just
because it's uh it's like a no breather
play I guess for a quarterback and he's
out there just throw it to him let him
run make a mess get a block but I'm
trying to figure out these Hall of Fame
numbers we're talking to Dan Marino with
a quarterback now like what numbers do
you get to to be a Hall of Fame
quarterback wide receivers you have to
have at least a thousand catches I'm
guessing yeah but the running back now
is different because we're not we don't
utilize or glamorize the running back as
much as we used to yeah I mean in
numbers I guess
really it's probably wins numbers I mean
I I haven't looked at what it is lately
so I don't know you know the last
quarterbacks that got in with their
numbers were who's the last guy to get
in it was a Kurt Warner yeah yeah so I
mean I don't know what his numbers are
but and I think it's probably you know
winning the Superbowl to is got to be a
big part of that
Eli Manning a Hall of Famer I would say
so he won two Super Bowls right but Jim
Plunkett won - yep and probably Jim
should be in - oh you think so
sure why not what else what do you think
what do you think um Plunkett wasn't
consistent enough Eli playing in New
York winning two Super Bowls his name
helps he beat the Patriots both times
right I don't think he's a great
quarterback but I think he was great in
two games when you needed to be great
you won Super Bowl so yeah I'm but he's
a player it's been there you know each
and every week for in place can you know
he's consistent playing a high level
four for a long time and won two Super
Bowls so he's Dan Marino joining us
behind on behalf of a Nutrisystem lose
weight improve your head go ahead give
the give the spiel I was fitzy doing
with his view I'm doing well my trying
to keep the weight off I got my
daughter's Bat Mitzvah coming up in a
few months and I gotta make sure that I
here comes the homies I got to do
another video
gift you got some snack bars there yes
I'm doing the right thing on the road
here right so the big thing is Monday
after the Super Bowl
super Monday for Nutrisystem go to
Nutrisystem calm but but really because
that's guys don't go on diets like
sometimes women do after January first
right guys wait till after football
after the playoffs after it even though
I didn't know yeah oh yeah yeah it's the
biggest so it's the biggest decision day
for men going on diet so yes forty this
is a lot to ask I'm gonna put number
thirteen on the spot but as opposed to
the video which was great what you did
for my son Jordan a couple years ago to
actually have Dan show up that would be
like to personally and they can do the
whole I'll get an impersonator to come
and do it thirteen Jersey that's it we
can probably we can make that work yeah
so there's a chance you'd show up for
the his daughters I'll give them hope
and say yes okay you can go to turbo
four men dot-com to get started today so
that's Nutrisystem turbo chicks yeah
yeah can you stay for a little while
yeah you sure yeah I don't know what you
got what do you got it's your show Brady
or or a Montana
it's it's it's Brady over Montana and
it's Elway over Montana there so okay I
said it and you're agreeing you're
shaking your hand yeah I like that I
like that all right we'll come back
you got how's the arm by the way I could
throw it still you want McLovin to try
to catch marinas not a game manager like
Alex but I'm not doing this why look at
me he looks like he can throw it through
my chest at two seconds with his left
hand we're gonna find out next could you
hit him in the chest and make his heart
stop his heart stopped yeah is that a
pot if I get warmed up a little bit yes
first row maybe not start getting warmed
up all right we're back with Dan Marino
after this first of all greatest some of
that that's good 18 years old
that's nice boss right there all right
to throw the work but get the ball boy
where's the hey you want this other Hill
here you want to be the other helmet
yeah this is too big all the things also
two big guys oh boy wait till we come
back around we're good you can bring the
noise I missed you a little bit down hi
okay here we go I'm gonna catch this one
what so you're saying Alex Smith is a
stronger arm than marina no dad can't
help me welcome to put on this yeah
lights good job back with us
representing the folks from Nutrisystem
always great to see him at the Super
Bowl so during the live look and McLovin
was taking his life into his own hands
there and did pretty well you you hung
in there as Dan three a couple passes
the first one he dropped but it was a
little off yeah a second hit him right
in chest Dan can't help but throw a
catchable ball I mean you don't get that
many yards by hitting people in the head
yeah throw you open to that's another
thing that's a word if I wanted to give
a message to you back in the huddle if I
was a wide receiver yeah could I do it
without you getting mad like what would
be the proper way to say I think you
missed me or well there's a story about
dooper once right so he never done ever
used to die for the ball so one time
he's post time and I jumped a little bit
so I'm like you know dive for the ball
and he just said well you're making all
the money hit me in the chest you got a
point there that's okay that's good but
can I go back to the huddle and say it
in a diplomatic way like I was hoping
you made yes but at the same time you
know and you get the film you see the
film and you're not open then I don't
trust you anymore but you would you're
we weren't afraid to bark at somebody
but would we I wouldn't say yeah I mean
I think that's kind of overrated a
little bit cuz it sometimes I'm mad at
myself okay or maybe the coaches but you
and my players you know not so much the
players himself do you see out tom yes
yeah I mean I could it's probably
himself and some of the coaches and
maybe the plays is being called whatever
maybe I also look at I was watching the
Pro Bowl and Drew Brees has this habit
of licking his fingers all the time you
started to warm up
soon as I get off yeah soon as I get a
full pot start licking my fingers it's
just something I have it I've done in my
whole life it's gross though it is
especially especially when I can put
your hands under a center yeah it's
summertime in Miami don't lick the
backside of your hand like the front
side but breeze does that you know who
else to do Phil Simms did that no he did
yeah he'd always explain what you do
with the dolphins and and what do you
think though the future here with the
Dolphins so I'm a special advisor I
spent time there it's helped out in all
areas of football and you know some of
the scouting stuff and and around the
team work with the CEO work with the
owner had a lot of fun you know being
around the players and some of the you
know doing player development stuff and
you know we were 6 and 10 and you can't
be happy about that as a team you know
we're looking forward to you know
getting better next year it's just
getting better overall as a team which
Jay Cutler's future Jays free so you
know I don't know what he's gonna come
back resume to TV I haven't talked to
him since the end of the years though
but it's still Tannehill team right yeah
yes right there's still a little bit of
a mystery with it like I don't know how
good he is he's he's very good and works
his butt off smart guy it's just gonna
you know it's gonna be here and played
in 18 months you know so you gotta get
him back but what role would you have or
do you have with him we spend time
together some meetings and stuff but you
know that's more of a personal thing
with me instead of you know discussing
ok we can go back to who's better
Montana or Brady if you will yeah we can
I could just start looking my there's
what do you expect to happen this
weekend if you were gonna be an analyst
looking at this game so I'd like to see
a good game obviously and being a
Pittsburgh guy are you ok with the
Eagles win yeah sure ok yeah maybe yeah
cuz New England's won so much hey we
want Philly to win right but um I think
for Philly to win you know it's the
obvious stuff that you're looking at and
you could probably talk about it to it
you got to keep Tom Brady on the
sidelines you know don't give him extra
possessions don't turn the ball over
they can run the ball keep him on the
sidelines and also I think you're gonna
you know gonna have to score at least 30
points you know cuz they're yeah so the
enormity of this game you know Foles has
been in the league but hasn't really I
mean he hasn't been on this stage you
and your second year go to a Super Bowl
did it help because you were sort of
young naive or did it hurt you because
you were young a night well I wouldn't
say I was naive but I think that I felt
like to a game of this yeah yeah yeah
yeah right so I I felt like I was gonna
be back I mean after we lost the game
you know it was like it's disappointing
obviously but I thought I was be back
and I never got back again so for him
this is a unique opportunity because he
is a backup and if you know when Stein
don't get hurt when's is the one playing
and probably in the future Wentz is
gonna be obviously the quarterback for
the Eagles so this is very unique for
him so you know I think it's you gotta
have that it to just turn it loose
because you know you might never know
when you're gonna get back so did you
ever think of playing it for another
team was there a moment in your career
that you could have yeah I could have
probably played for Minnesota they was
interested in me Pittsburgh Steelers how
close not very close so so yeah just cuz
health-wise you know I just I thought
about it for sure I thought about it
that's when they had Randy Moss no boys
Carter and that could have been fun oh
boy that would have been pretty good
come on you did you're healthy you all
you do is stand there and throw right no
you gotta be able to get out of the way
well you always were able to slide in
the pocket like you could feel it sure
and we see that with Brady but he does
have yeah he's very good can you teach
that I think it's just a sense of over
time your parking awareness how you how
you feel like the cly talking about the
clock in your head like you know what
the pattern is you know what you're
throwing if it's gonna be a quick out or
a long Pat whatever it is so you know
what when you got to get rid of that
that clock and the clock again so and
then if you got to move so that's Tom's
very good
that Paulie what so pans longest run
longest run career damn wait let me see
do you know your longest run down you
did it twice 15 yards 15 yards is
correct as a rookie and then again at
age 29
oh there you go look at that elusive I
think yes I think how about my career
rushing you want to go closest closest
to the hole to career rushing yards 87
87 is correct you're one of the few
athletes who knows all no because that's
such a unique stat yeah right so that's
very proud of 87 yards rushing in 17
years how many touchdowns nine rushing
touchdowns all quarterback sneaks no no
I ran some in lieu legs like like
there's no way they thought we actually
have a bootleg video where he faked a
handoff you can't see even offensive
lineman in the picture there's nobody in
the picture he looks like the game had
been stopped you ran for a touchdown
there's just nobody there
it wasn't snow I think yes yeah do you
think explain this that Ben
Roethlisberger says he is not allowed to
call a quarterback sneak how was that
would that be I don't understand that
you don't understand why he's not a lot
of cold he says that because you know
you see Brady run it all the time and
you think Ben as big as he is could get
a yard if they needed to and they said
we do I'm not allowed to audible to a
quarterback sneak that doesn't make
sense
yeah you think if the front is right you
should be able to even then you have a
signal like I remember like guys
quarterbacks would say if you if I
pinched you or tapped you or many
quarterbacks things you didn't know but
did you have a word that you know it was
just the regular snap count Oh was
anybody else no you were doing it just
there's no weed called in a huddle a lot
of times so I didn't really I don't ever
remember checking to a quarterbacks oh
good call and run it yeah but here's
Brady the oldest guy in the league
running quarterback sneaks and then Ben
says I'm not allowed to do that
interesting mm-hmm
give your plug one more time for the
turbo yeah it's the turbo shake star go
pro shakes and the fact that Monday is
the biggest decision day for four men as
far as you know diets are concerned and
and go to Nutrisystem calm what else
yeah stuff it's always great for guys
yeah yes point we all love that Dan's
wearing ankle socks at seven degree
weather Minnesota oh yeah play golf he
just wants that socks ready their visit
turbo for men calm to get started today
the great Dan Marino it's great to see
you Danny for more Dan Patrick show to
the audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]